wendy good morning how are you doing my
husband and i have children from
previous relationships and a little over
a year ago
he had an affair with one of
our children's moms so i'm wondering
kind of what are our appropriate
boundaries and how we kind of move
forward from that
there's a lot on that one man so
walk me through just some some of the
complexities how long have you
and your current husband been married uh
june will be five years
five years okay and then how many kids
did he bring to this
partnership two from two separate
relationships
okay so you a relationship number three
yes okay do you have any kids together
one okay so he brought in two kids
y'all made one and then how many kids
did you bring
one okay from one other relationship
yes all right so you have
four kids total
one you brought in one together and then
two he brought in from two different
people okay
so you have um one two
three four five different adults
navigating this relationship together
right
right plus um my daughters
dad is married so we have we co-parent
well with her
with her stepmom so we have energy
okay all right so i don't know if you've
ever sat down and just
mapped this out like i'm doing right
here just to start this
that's a call it's a lot right it's a
family forest
we don't have a family tree yes you've
got
yes you've got a family forest here um
so
give me a sense of your demeanor
are you somebody that laughs a lot
through life are you somebody that holds
to control tightly like
tell me who you are oh man
i am a control freak at its finest
all right i am very 100
90 percent of the time so i like things
to be
stable and to go typically in the
direction that i
have planned for it to go
a little out of why i i
get anxious about it so just taking a
stab at this
you spend a lot of your time anxious is
that right
oh yeah okay um and you
after a series of
seasons being highly anxious there's
just seasons when you want to lay in bed
and not get out of bed and just watch
netflix is that fair
that's accurate okay so tell me about
this guy that you married
um he's the total opposite he is very
laid back
so with the flow he doesn't get
he he's never really shown a temper
about anything
you know something starts to bothering
it has to be something pretty serious
um he is actually he's a detective so
a lot at work and then i think when he
comes home he doesn't really want to
deal with a lot at home too right so
he's he's a
he's a police detective he is
okay so i my dad was one so i grew up in
a house with the detective so i've i
they're very unique extraordinary yet
unique individuals right so i
got you on that so
um so he a couple years into your
marriage was it right when you were
having a baby or right around that
season
uh no it was after okay probably she's
a little over one and a half okay i'm
gonna
i'll i'll i'll call her a newborn until
she's about three before
your life becomes any semblance of
normal again okay
and folks with three-year-olds right now
are like they're not normal fair enough
so then he goes back to visit baby mama
of one or two or three of which he's got
three now
and they end up hooking up do they have
they just have a one-night stand or they
have a rekindled their relationship walk
me through what happened
um
talk directly into the phone okay sorry
yeah okay we were kind of at a little
bit of a rough patch in our marriage
i was really anxious about the
situations that we were going through
just with his work and then with having
to co-parent with all of these people
so i went out of town for an interview
and while i was gone he basically
just he confided in her
told her lots of things that i had told
him out of
safety you know not really expecting any
of that to ever come out
and then he told her and then that led
to
an encounter just one time and then when
i came back home
um probably that following week
he he told me everything that happened
so he didn't try to keep it a secret
but that's kind of where we was he
remorseful and upset or did he just say
hey by the way
no he was remorseful he's tried really
hard to move past this
and work on our marriage and reassure me
this is not going to happen again
sure um and so
that was a year ago and you stayed with
him so tell me what surfaced recently
that's making you wonder
how do we move on how do i how do i
reconcile this and keep going
well he's pretty adamant that
i have to make a decision
he wants things to be resolved between
me and his child's mother
and i'm a firm no
um she's not been remorseful about it
and as soon as she found out that i knew
it was well i need to tell her my side
of the story it was never
i'm sorry this happened this was a
mistake and it's been
a total not take responsibility
at all and that's just to me
i don't want to deal with it like i'm
going to therapy working on me
and if you're not making positive steps
to work on you
there's no benefit in this but i think
his biggest fear
is that the child is going to recognize
that there is an issue there
because i don't have any interaction
with her whatsoever but i also don't
feel like i have to
he has a dad that takes care of him and
a mom and when he's with us
i love him so much i take care of him
i don't allow my feelings for her to
impact how i
love him if that makes sense yeah
and so when what is the picture of this
mythical relationship your husband
envisions that you
and one of the other baby mamas has does
he want you all to hang out and go get
margaritas together
what i mean what does he picture i think
he
well i mean we talked about this friday
again
it was basically you at least need to
acknowledge one another's existence
when you're around one another and you
know but prior to this happening
um we had a good relationship you know
we would go through things with the kids
all of us i mean we did birthday parties
together we were
unusual in that we could get along in a
healthy way
but then after that happened it was kind
of like well i trusted you
you broke this trust not just in a
little way but this was my marriage
right and you're not remorseful so i
don't know i
want to be okay in the
hate but that's it like i don't want i
don't want a friendship and i think he
wants the friendship to be there so that
there's not an offer of tension that
is obviously there sure so
man i'm just gonna speak directly from
my heart is that okay
yeah that's fun all right so number one
you married a guy
that has gotten three different women
pregnant and had three different kids by
three different moms
okay right so there should be no
surprise as to what you got tangled up
in
is that fair yeah now we all
want us to believe that we're going to
be the one that helps change somebody we
all want to be that person that i'm
going to be so
desirable i'm going to be so loved that
loving that this isn't going to fill in
the blank and it did it happened to you
that sucks
right that doesn't give him an excuse to
cheat on you it doesn't give him excuse
to
go disclose intimate things to somebody
the hard part here is is that he's had
an intimate
relationship with three different people
right he's
grown humans with three different people
that's
intimate moments and so what you guys
need to do is have a boundaries
conversation if you haven't already
and not a fight not a war but a
here's the things that i want to be ours
in this relationship
and normally that's things like kids and
home and not other women that's not
going to be your relationship because
you're going to have to share your home
with other people's kids
you're gonna have to share your home
with other women and what i mean by
other women is there's gonna be other
women coming to your house to pick up
kids you're gonna have to drop kids off
that's just gonna be the nature of this
and as they get older
and you're navigating basketball games
and ymca stuff
it's just going to be more and more and
more right that's the path you chose
when you married this guy doesn't mean
that it's not the right path i'm just
telling it's going to be more complex
and that leads me to part two here is
yeah
he violated your marriage covenant he
did
and that other lady violated your
marriage covenant
she did and you chose to stay
and you chose to continue to um
raise this baby this kid when when your
husband's got custody
which is part of being married to him
right and so that means you're going to
have to interact with her
does that mean you got to be friends no
does that mean you're going to call her
the next
one time something great happens no but
i do think that means you're
deciding to opt into a life where you've
got to be a civil adult
and your husband's right your kids are
going to learn
how you interact with people that you
are frustrated with or disagree with
they're going to learn that by watching
you
they don't have to know that hey dad
re-hooked up with baby mama again you
know what i mean
and that doesn't mean you have to be
okay with that what happened was wrong
it's not cool it was a violation of
everything about your marriage what i
don't want to see happen is
you continue you stay you forgive him
he's working his butt off to be right
he's
he is trying to change he's working hard
and
one year two year three years later
you're keep continuing to hang up
hang this over with him right because
then at some point it becomes your
challenge
either cut bait or be all back in but
you can't be all in
sort of with one foot and a couple of
toes
and that means being all in with this
guy means you're gonna have to interact
with her if you ever sat down with her
and just said hey
let's just talk what would that
conversation be like
um that's kind of that's what he wanted
but why won't you sit down with her and
say hey look we have
at least 15 years left of interacting
with each other
at a minimum and you're going to be
sitting on one side of my husband and
i'm going to be sitting on the other
side at this kid's graduation
we're going to go to the same wedding
like we're in it now
what the hell ha like why in the world
would you hook up with my husband
like what what keeps that conversation
from happening
is it be just because she didn't run to
you and say i'm so sorry
no i mean it's just the pain that comes
with that
yeah i have
such a serious complex with
um abandonment and rejection that i work
with and she speaks to those things
because she's angry at me too like it's
a constant
attack on me as a person and i don't
the idea of sitting down with someone
and hearing those things just
it hurts i don't want to i don't want to
do that
i got you no it's hey that's brave that
you're saying that out loud and i
appreciate that
so here's a hard thing i'm gonna tell
you i'm gonna try to do it gently okay
um moving forward with that pain that
you have
and not addressing it for the next 15
years is going to be
really hard really hard it's going to be
heavy
you can navigate it because you're tough
and you can navigate it because i think
your husband loves his kids
but it's gonna be really hard and
sitting down and having a one or two
time hard conversation is going to be
really hard
one of those leads to healing much much
sooner
one of those leads to putting those
bricks down much much sooner
and if you think about it from her eyes
you may be the woman that he left
her for right yeah
you may be both having the exact same
feelings about each other
about this one dude right and
there can be some common ground empathy
there is it gonna feel good
no i'm just trying to brat my head and
be in your situation
dude you know what i mean i can't even
fathom it
but i'm trying to put myself in a
situation where i can look down
five years ten years fifteen years down
the road and say
this only ends in a train wreck this
just doesn't get better it just festers
and then at some point the kid turns 12
or 15 and starts asking questions and
there's just poison in the water or
i can bite down on my mouthpiece this is
a fighting reference i can bite down on
my mouthpiece and i can just wait in
there
and i can call her and say i'm tired of
hurting and i think you start that
conversation with
i have a fear of abandonment and
rejection and this was really hard on me
this is a year ago is
not getting better it's just getting
worse and
we've got to be grown-ups and solve this
for the sake of our babies
we got to solve this for the sake of
moving on and
i i just don't see a way around that
wendy i don't see a way that you move
forward with any sort of peace in your
life
and any sort of peace in your marriage
any sort of
wellness in your life that just the
constant cycle of inflammation is gonna
make you
sicker it's going to make you your body
break down over time
all this is going to just continue to
happen because you've got this
heat in your life that's not going to go
away and i know you don't want to have
that conversation i cannot see a way
forward
a path towards healing without that
conversation
i don't think it's going to be easy it
might be actually
and it might be a moment where you all
end up weeping hard
and getting frustrated at each other and
crying and hugging and then
agreeing to be adults and even if one of
you has the courage to say we're not
gonna be best friends let's just say
that but we've got to do this for the
sake of
these kids um i think there could be a
lot of healing there
can that happen i don't know man that
takes two super mature people
um that's the hope and here's the thing
i'm hoping for that
wendy i'm hoping that our country can do
that i'm hoping that people
on both sides of political i also can
sit down and say you have hurt me wave
you do things on the reg on a regular
basis you have a view of family you have
a view of money
you have a view of fill in the blank
that i think hurts me
but man not addressing this not being
adults not
being real and not being honest and just
yelling and fighting and avoiding
is just going to kick this and kick this
and kick this and we're going to teach
our kids how to do it
and we're going to teach their kids how
to do it until the whole thing falls
over
or we can
reach out with that first text message
wendy to this woman and say
it's been a year this is going to be a
hard conversation but i'd love just you
and me
to go have brunch one morning and
i'm gonna be an adult and i hope you
will too and i know it's gonna be a
heavy conversation but for the sake of
our kids can we just get together and
meet and talk
and um that's my challenge to you wendy
it's not gonna be easy i know
if you have that conversation um my gut
tells me it's gonna be a tough
brave healing conversation and i'd love
love love for you to call me back and
let me know how it goes
and you are not seeking validation you
are not seeking her forgiveness you are
not seeking her apology
you are seeking peace and you can know i
went first i went forward and i
heard out i listened i paid for the meal
and then we moved on so thank you so
much for your call wendy please let me
know how that conversation goes
and i hope you will be continuing to be
brave and have that conversation
and tell your husband come on man stop
three kids three different moms stop
stop
stop okay
every detective out there needs to have
a therapist in their life because the
job is hard y'all get to see things you
interact with people in
ugly and hard ways you do a trauma all
day long you gotta have somebody in your
life that's helping you heal
and i know you all are smart and y'all
are trained to walk into rooms and see
things that nobody else does
and you have to experience things that
nobody else does i know that because i
lived with it
that doesn't mean you're immune to being
a person
go get the help you need get the help
you need